what's up your crack [ __ ] welcome to
oh wait that's the wrong channel
thousand gum resumes yeah
welcome to lurking this game looks
really cool oh Jesus that's awesome so
it's supposed to use to your microphone
and it's a sound based horror game which
um oh god it's coming closer I like this
interact create sound with cue so I
guess that's the thing huh I thought you
would be blind in the game but I guess
not what bury it so so my footsteps is
creating a nice this is kind of like
pulse if you brush your Mamba cool can I
create a sound
I love bulbs oh that's cool
it works ball sack Oh God whoa I'm a sad
it's benign octopus thank God hello I
can see you you know see to crouch for
through da it works perfectly all right
so I'm a blind man or its noises whoa oh
those may make extra noise cow hey cool
alright I'll be taking you this is an
audio log scatter around Pacita listen
yeah mine cake $1300 interesting finally
moving into human trials
is working to be great just looking at
me how does he know where I am
stop where did he go
seriously the way the [ __ ] did he go
this is creeping me out all right water
bottle what's up and not much it's gonna
throw you around are that's okay
hey I'm still a fan no your water bottle
can't be a fan man I mean I am afraid
shut up
well they can't Anya's here what about
oh my god
a completa not an email you're now trash
[ __ ] street trash to be specific
where's my why is my water ball okay
okay all right come here wait a battle
you and I are gonna have fun
I love you pills wait what did you say
your name was again what a bottle yeah
but your real name
Oh God Oh God [ __ ] that what is time
sprockets
my name is Jennifer [ __ ] oh god I knew
it
what are they doing hello oh ha ha
but what the [ __ ] alright if they hear
me bad thing that not
oh so creepy so creepy oh god they can
hear me walk ship to run damn dun Dada
Dada Dada Dada and I'm very slow
actually
alright let's go up here I don't like it
fish
listen freaky [ __ ] me what's going on in
here what hello it's anyone out there
okay you're laughing really weirdly I
don't like okay that is so creepy man
what is he doing oh god he's fapping
isn't he that is a furious fat much
respect to him oh god he's right there
oh my god I thought it we were gonna be
fine I thought you were just having a
fat party like a normal Wednesday
Kalamata oh God
click [ __ ] ah alright we did it we
chose I'm fine
she Carrie Shakira Oh baby when you talk
like that you make a pretty girl man
hey boy that's not how you bureau I told
him not to eat the bureau's god damn it
I'm gonna have to set Gandalf straight
come on man you're being totally uncool
right now I gotta have to throw a book
in his face I stay on the way you'll
learn sir door somewhere
ha ha ha ha ah many voters saw Dan very
can go freely blonde among over he'll
he'll birthday alright let's try that
again
yeah right now Shakira Shakira oh god oh
god so creepy they just tell apart
oh just want to motorboat no I want to
go on a motorboat can I dream please
without being judged God
alright tomato canned soup what's that
pads go or you're my oh god oh god oh
god okay
oh god oh god don't GAD okay okay
I have tomato soup you're my only friend
tomato soup oh god you're my friend
tomato soup go tomato soup go for
freedom and justice and salad potato
salad specifically Oh God okay
Oh God alright adspend great eats my
face now goddamn potato salad you never
trust them until you know them it's like
a you have to build a bond
Oh God potato salad come here potato
salad go potato salad make me proud
potato salad go right now alright now
he's coming
alright potato salad we share it I have
some in my mouth you said we'd be potato
salads together but I think you someone
know buzz was lying shut shut shut shut
shut shut shut shut up
- it'll twice girl god damn it how am I
supposed to pass them I have an idea
it's just enough crazy - that it might
work go potato salad
I choose you they get you salad
Jennifer daddy fit pants you sold me out
Danya god damn you Jennifer sorry miss
I'm sorry
I promised me your signature I wear
inherent yarn ah an audio log let's pack
you up go Mia drawn to the area Jennifer
don't you [ __ ] day
don't you dare [ __ ] shame I would
never cheat on you
shut up I'm going faster I'm sorry I'm
sorry about your god sorry not shut
shouldn't have sold her out like that
Alyssa good block next time Jennifer God
if you if you're gonna be fat go be fat
in front of them all right
stupid morning bake that off pick that
up
pick that up Emma half cup hell yeah how
they strike compare how do you love you
well you obviously don't love me enough
Oh God but don't be scared
shut up just distract them with your
fattiness but you said it was beautiful
you're not beyond arcadia could you have
Jennifer I love she pets - shut up
they could hear you Jennifer shut pierce
you came back for me
sure sure that's it I came back yes
don't leave me scat shut up you'll be
fine be fine I'll come back for you I
promise ok parents I'll wait here
stupid batch yes
Hardman that was hard
all right what do we got here we're
almost out lamb your shoulder out didn't
you I'll come come on
as if you wouldn't do the same Oh God
that you really made a noise in you all
Riley's you oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
lamp you're my only hope man don't [ __ ]
this up for me please while I add an Shh
shut up he's gonna have us what his hair
shut up lab oh come on [ __ ] maka phone
hello
oh I do find out why like uh man all
right we're going we're going we're
going we're going you would go in we go
in we thirsty
we know that's best oh so I can't I
can't I can't ha ha ha ha
freaked me out so much oh oh oh oh
please be over I don't wanna play this
anymore
and we're back
that was awesome that was a really
[ __ ] creepy gay man
damn damn Ranga batang of Ranga all
right that was awesome that was really
cool wasn't it I thought that was cool
thank you for watching this entire video
aren't you special stay awesome bros
thank you for leaving it like it this
video as always I really appreciate it
and I'll see you tomorrow with a new
video
brofist